Oh, so today we should uh go through the
finally the identification of uh of
dynamic uh systems. Uh we were already
doing some pretty dynamic stuff at the
at the last lecture where we were
talking about the filtration of uh of
dynamic signals. I was there promising
yes we will uh we will slowly transition
from the from the static discussions to
uh to actually
uh discussion about the filters which
themselves are are dynamic systems
because the filters transfer functions
is the same thing the two sides of the
of the of the same same coin.
For example, in our low pass filter, we
wanted to have the what's it the gain of
the of the filter to be one to correctly
uh represent our long-term long-term
trends. We could choose the choose the
time constant in order to filter the
noise that we considered to be to be
noise.
And uh we have
also found out that this filtration can
be achieved by something which we called
finite impulse uh response finite
impulse response model or finite impulse
response filter. The two two sides of
the of the of the same coin. Uh we b
basically established this equation just
by uh looking at the moving average
moving weighted uh weighted average and
uh this uh this type of model is uh is
one of the first models one can one can
try in the identification of uh of
dynamic dynamic systems. So we will get
get back to this and uh as uh as
promised uh last time uh for example if
we if we needed uh if we needed this uh
fear filter to to represent to represent
the filter we we might be again
interested in the in the gain. So low
pass filter would typically have the
have the gain of uh of one. High pass
filter would be would be close to close
to
zero. Any any questions to this?
You you saw this in your in your
exercises.
uh
so
today first I I would like to demystify
what stands behind this finite impulse
response. It's maybe good how or it
maybe extends how to think about the
dynamic systems the model of dynamic
systems
and what's up yak
Okay.
Painkillers. Okay. And
uh so demystify it. And then
finally, okay. What we are what we are
used to what is uh probably a task of
identification that you have already
already done. uh a
typical typical example. I have some
time domain. At some point I do
a I uh involve a step in my in my input.
I I measure the response of some of some
plant something like something like
this. And then I'm trying to to find out
some sort of a some sort of a model that
would that would represent that would
represent this uh this plant. Let's say
this is
y
measured and well there are some some
textbook uh textbook uh methods how to
uh how to pro how to process this uh
step step responses.
uh you you have seen straits uh method
but the question is do I all the do I
every time get the data data like this
so is is it always that somebody will
give me here is the nice uh step
response uh we only uh jumped with with
one signal at a at a time we measured
everything everything correctly it's not
going to be the the case always. So the
question is how to how to generalize
this. Um so
one one one type of this uh of this
generalization uh let's maybe get to
this
uh what do we mean by finite fir finite
[Music]
impulse impulse
response. Where does this where does
this come from? This is
impulse. Basically, we we can get uh
back in the in the uh past or let's
let's say back to the first thoughts
about some some dynamic systems. U we
traditionally represent some dynamic
system
some input input output uh
box and
uh what uh you are already already used
to is that hm it's not uh not always
always good or it's not good at all to
live in this in this time domain. So
it's uh much better if I represent all
these all these signals in
the in the
laplas laplas domain.
Uh why why is it why is it so? uh in the
laplas domain we can calculate the
output based on of course the input that
influence the systems as the system and
based on some representation of the of
the dynamics and what we typically do
what we try to try our systems to uh to
resemble or to look like is uh is to to
to have some linear dynamics that can be
represented by the by the transfer
function. Uh what does this transfer
function function uh really really do
and what is uh what would be its time
representation? So if I'm in this in
this picture, if I'm just staying in the
in the time domain, well, I would use
here some equivalent of the g of s. So g
of
t. And the question is what is this?
What is this g of t? Um well, we can
just try our laplas uh laplas transfer
knowledge. So if our uh g of s would be
which
one just let's just do the simplest
possible possible
thing. How is this
function function going to look like in
the in the time domain?
Exponential.
Mhm. What kind of
one - one there? There must there must
be t in front
of exponential as well.
So minus one.
Yeah. So the what was it? I what what I
what I kind of remember is if I have s
plus a then it uh then it back
transforms to e to the minus a t
right okay so if
we if we use
this ah this is the plus
It's the
or or let's make let's make it Yeah,
let's make it even even
simpler. So that something like
this minus
well the a is one one over t, right?
t /ed by by t. Okay.
Also, shouldn't there be time constant
from exponential
because we changed the Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
I I I should have but but but I'm just
trying to to make a simple example. So,
let's let's imagine this this example
was there was there at first. uh it I
mean it it wouldn't matter if if if it
if there is uh this uh well instead of
one if there is one one over t so how
does this uh g of
t g of t look like
[Music]
um if we
are let's say we go from zero to some to
some t so at at zero we we get what
uh e to the e to the zero. So we get
either one or some constant that is
standing in in
front. Let's do
some colors. Yeah, let's let's leave the
colors for the for the
later.
Um and then what should what should what
should happen as the time time goes to
infinity let's uh let's assume that the
that the capital t is is positive so we
will just just drop to
zero
okay what does
What does this represent? I I guess uh I
guess you might have discussed this or
you didn't discuss it at all at your
theory of automatic automatic control.
What what does this g of s uh alone uh
represents? What is this what is this g
of tial?
No.
uh no it's already a solution to a
differential equation. So if uh if
our if
our input is how to write it
well if our input would be this unit
step we get a we get a step response out
of uh out of y of s. But if
our so this is step
response but what if
our
[Music]
input would be this mysterious delta
which is which is nothing else than than
[Music]
some idealized uh impulse. Yeah,
something something like like this. And
uh well, if you look it up in the in the
laplas laplas table, actually it's uh
it's uh
transpose one of
us or just one it's uh it's
llas transformer it's laplas image is
one. So basically the response of the
system to
the to some impulse. So impulse means uh
what I just I just open a valve and then
and then close it. Uh whether it's a
valve which is uh feeding some liquid to
a to a tank whether it's a valve at the
at this uh heating
radiator whatever like that. So
basically our G of S G of T is nothing
else than the response to the
impulse
or impulse impulse response.
[Music]
That's why there is the impulse response
in the in the in the name of this finite
impulse response uh model. So the word
finite we will we will get uh get to to
that.
Um just maybe think of this function for
a for for a second. Doesn't it really
look like a like a like an impulse
response? Yeah, just think of think of
this kind of this kind of input. I have
my tank uh fed by uh by some liquid with
a constant flow rate and I just for a
bit moment bit of the moment I uh I'm
going from the steady state just by
doing the doing the impulse like sudden
twist and then going back with with some
with some valve. Well, what would
happen? Well, we are in the steady state
then the response to the impulse if we
are talking about the first order system
would be would be immediate and then
this whatever the whatever happened with
the valve will slowly disappear over the
time. Everybody somehow okay with this?
All right, with this representation
uh so we might think well this is so
nice and
intuitive if you if we give it give it a
thought after after some time. So why is
it why is it that we are using the the
laplas transform? This is why we use a
laplas transform because if we now take
and we want to we want to calculate the
the response of the dynamic system in
the time domain. Well from the notation
side nothing changes much. We
just we just uh
basically take into account what is the
input to the dynamic system and what are
the properties of the dynamic system.
How would it react to the to the change
in the in the input. But this uh
innocently looking star actually is
uh is just uh representing some ugly
thing which is called a convolution
integral or this is also called well
convolution convolution
product whatever whatever you you might
want
it and the
integral
Let's let's do it. Uh which
way? There are two equivalent ways to
write it and I never remember which one
is good for this
lecture.
U T
minus
DTO. And the other equivalent way is
just flipping
this t minus to
ut doesn't look doesn't look at as as
easy at the at the at the at the first
glimpse. Let's just try to demystify it.
What is an integral? integral is trying
to do like infinite infinite sum sum
over the infinite decimal uh portions of
of
time. So let's say we have
some input and
output. I don't know some something like
this. Now uh
Let's say that we are at the particular
particular time time
tk. This is the output of a of a dynamic
system. And since the system is is
dynamic, it it keeps the memory of what
happened happened in the in the past.
And uh well what happened in the past is
basically uh shown and for in the in the
graph of the of the input and in the
middle well this is the this is the
reaction uh of uh of a system how it
reacts basically basically to each input
that happened in the in the past. Let
me let me somehow
somehow explain
that. So at the current point in time
uh what
uh the dynamic system would maybe barely
react to the to the input at the current
at the current point but it would react
to uh how much valve to to some tongue
was opened one second ago. Yeah. So it
reacts to to these these past inputs. So
basically it would it would take into
account the uh tk minus one t k minus 2
and and so
on.
But if we go if we go far enough in the
in the past, we will quite uh quite
likely encounter a point where well the
input how how was the flow rate to the
to the tank maybe one year ago? Well, it
wouldn't matter for for the for for for
now. Yeah. So that's why uh that's why
uh
we take this function to our to our help
and this function now uh basically flips
its axis. That's why we have that's why
we have this representation.
So this function would just now start
start living living in the in in the
past. So basically it should say what uh
for the input that happened long time
ago let's say at
point at point
zero that happened long time ago. So
let's say at point at point zero it
would
actually it would
actually is it correct
order did I write in correct
order something tells me that the DS I'm
just not interpreting it correctly t
minus
which
happened a long time
ago.
Well
ah. So what is
this? We are plugging
in
to so long time ago we
are we are at the current point in time
t this one. So the T goes in here and in
here
and it now calculates what is the
influence of
the current input for
the for the
output. No, I got lost there.
I have to I have to start start it
somehow some somehow again the the whole
point is
the function g of
t g of t becomes
uh becomes like a like a weight.
So let's maybe try to do it like this.
So the the function will
uh take the value
uh at at different point in time and
wait the
corresponding corresponding outputs
basically basically backwards. So it
will weight the current inputs and those
which happened in the
um in the recent
past much higher than those inputs. So
you have to imagine it like as we are
traveling traveling back in time we are
basically spreading to the to the left
here and to the to the right here.
That's what this what this minus uh
should should signify.
So the input which happened long in long
in the past would be weighted very very
very uh
less. Does this make
sense? Yes or no?
This is the question whether uh whether
the weather on uh 23rd of April 2024
uh influence the weather that we have
that we have
today very little. Yeah. One year ago.
But the weather that we had yesterday of
course influenced influenced the the
weather that that we have that we have
here. And the rest is just the just the
mathematics.
Um but this is this has tons tons of
applications
inverse like if you start at time z and
go to t. Mhm. The time is like the
current time is it?
Uh no no no.
Um
so there would be so current time would
be how would it be represented? Current
time is here.
We
will we will take uh so this is the what
is the what is the current uh current
output the current output is
influenced h Jakob how do you how do you
understand this
yeah it's a it's basically
I mean yeah the the graph is correct.
Yeah this this is the the reaction. So
if at at this point in time we have this
this input the influence of this
particular input at this particular
point in time to the future would be
like this. But at the next point in time
there will be a new input which will
have its own influence. That's why we we
are doing the the integral and now the
whole problem comes when we are
interpreting it when we are trying to
see it like what what gave us our past
data the database in the data that we
that we want to that we want to process.
Yeah. So that's that's why the input
back to the back in the in the past
would be would be weighted less. So
that's why Yeah. That's why there is
there is this minus. There should be toe
here. That's why I'm that's why I'm I
was
confused.
Yeah.
Okay. So if you buy this has tons of
applications. There are even
convolutional neural networks. Let's
just write this is convolution has tons
of applications in the image processing
but of course in the in the control in
the in the modeling. So now uh this will
be a sort of idealized uh uh even
infinite uh
uh infinite uh impulse response model.
So our finite impulse response model. So
how did it look like? We
set we just
wind wind back uh to
our to our previous lecture. Where are
you? Ah this guy
here. So y k is equal to sum. And we
were doing basically the same thing. we
were
traveling uh into the into the past with
our with our control
inputs. So y k sum
of i going to one going from one to m b
i
u k k k k k k k k k k k k k k k k k k k
k k k k k k k k k k k k k k k k k k k k
k k k minus
i and
well we can start start comparing these
expressions. So maybe now this sort of
they are completely completely
equivalent this this sort of formulation
uh give us give us more sense because
here the the input is traveling
traveling back to time. So it's says
says again the same thing it would be
just an approximation the input at the
at the time tk at time time k is given
as a influence correction collection
accumulation of what happened in the
past. So here the
integral is replaced already it's uh uh
already only contains several several
terms.
The coefficients BI are basically uh
some some
samples some something like if
we if
we need some different color.
[Music]
If we just sort of uh sample sample this
uh this function at at the discrete
point. So yeah that would be our B1
B2 B3 uh
coefficients and uh we are just taking
our taking our our past past values of
uh of the of the inputs.
Any questions to this
comments? At least barely
comprehensible.
Good. Let's go now to the to the
practical side of this. Let's let's get
back to to our question. Well, now we
know our model can represent many
different uh situations. How do we how
do we train this model? So let's
just assume that uh we have uh conducted
some experiment and let let's let's try
let's start from the from the step
response because we we under understand
it and let's try to
see how we can use this use this model
for train uh well how how we can use the
data for training. this model.
Um, so what's our what's our
assumption? Let's say at certain certain
time point I think we can easily easily
call it uh call it zero. We make a step
response and what would it
mean? How would this look like in the
output?
Let's say let's say something something
like this is
done maybe
use yeah something like this that we
don't have uh don't have the need or
don't have the assumption that the gain
of
our of our dynamic system would be would
be
one. Um good. So uh if we should if we
should uh train the model that would
predict this that would behave similarly
to the data that we observed then
well our our predictions should kind of
should kind of fit it.
So this is of course zero here.
So what can we say or or predict at
about the about the input uh sorry about
the output at the time zero. So it's the
it's a time when when the step just uh
just occurred and uh maybe we well we
haven't even uh measured what what
happened to the to the output. So we
can we can just say okay this one
uh our output still at this point didn't
uh didn't notice that that some change
in the in the input
happened the fun will
start we will start now so based on
based on
our our model equation
Let's try
to to see
uh how how how would this this
prediction equation would be would be
written. So if we take
the the the sum we need to have what
B1
and we would take we would take what
what
uh uh what index of
U zero right because so what happens
here our K is one and we are just doing
the first sum from the from the sum. So
I is I is
one. This one was the is the easy
one. What can
we what can we write for the for the
B2? What kind of
uh what kind of index will the U have?
[Music]
Mhm. Yeah. So,
one one time back back into the
uh one one step back to the back to the
past which well according to our
assumptions here they are all all
zeros right.
So this is this is just zero because we
are just thinking about the about the
the step response. So the same would
then happen
and our first
prediction. So if we now take the B
M which one will will that
be which index of
U minus M K - M. Uh okay but our K is
one. Yeah. So 1 minus M. Exactly. Very
good. Yeah.
Uh of course we we assume step response.
So our our input u was zero in all these
past
moments. Yeah. Now we can even even see
why why we wrote that this is zero here
because well we are just
assuming b1 * 0 b2 * 0 plus b
m bm *
0. Okay. H let's let's try to
do another uh another
another prediction of our of our
model. How will how will this one this
one go? So only K changed.
[Music]
one
uh can be but we can we can already
already be uh it's going to be
just one time larger index
makes sense.
Yeah. So
B1 U1 good question Yakob whether
whether these are these are ones uh we
can we can just uh just keep them keep
them general and uh it it will help us
to to to to generalize this
uh is this correct?
Yes. So as Adam says our B2 is now
taking what? U
Z
plus and so
on. What will this guy be?
2 minus
[Music]
m which sounds like
uh we will be just now repeating this
this pattern.
what what does it mean?
Uh my output at the time point two is
just given by the by the past. So past
means the previous one. So 2 - one at
one 2 - 2 2 - 3 until 2 minus whatever
this this number m is.
And it would mean okay if we if we hit
the if we hit the the time point M how
would this look
like?
Maybe or maybe not.
No. How to get
minus one?
N minus one. Yeah. Yeah. It's back one
on one one step into the
past.
B2. This guy here.
Yeah, you got it now. Now it's easy,
right? And what about this guy here?
U zero. Yeah. So
while while this one well that was still
still zero based on
our based on our uh assumption of the of
the input shape. Now we will actually
have every every every term here will
will be some uh some
nonzero non-zero number. Uh we can also
um so some time point time point m was
some time point that we ran out of the
of the coefficients of our of our model.
But well we can also predict in more
more into the into the future or let's
say we have more more data. We have the
the whole uh step response. So how would
even more general let's say we have n
capital n number of the of the data
points. How would that that look like as
a
prediction? U N - one
U N - one
N.
[Music]
Yes. Yeah. It's like a crossroad. It's
like sudoku. Yeah. Once you once you
know the once you know the pattern we
get there. Uh why are we why are we do
doing this? Well, if you just uh if we
just come back to our to our linear
regression. Well, we were trying to
trying to build some matrices and then
we plug in some uh some of our data
points uh in order to estimate the
parameters.
Well, how did we get there? Basically,
we build up where was our matrix? Yeah,
we built this this sort of a this sort
of a
[Music]
matrices. Where is the expression I'm
looking
for? Okay, this one. Yeah, basically
built built this form because our our
model was uh was
linear. Our prediction model was
linear. So let's now think what is uh
what is the what is that we know and
that is what is that we want to
estimate. Well, the left hand side the
outputs. Well, that's the step response
that we that we measured. Yeah. At
discrete time points and our U1, U, U
u0, U1,
U2, whatever whatever inputs are are
also data that we know. and our unknowns
are of course these these uh these
parameters but they all are all all
enter linearly here. So what we can now
do is the very same thing that we have
done in the in the linear regression. We
can just now build some matrix of of
this or some matrix equation of this
sort where the vector P would contain
all
our all
our data
points. So let's let's try it. How would
it how would it look like?
[Music]
um doesn't doesn't really make sense to
start with y not unless we would like to
like to estimate it but that's already
something advanced. Let's just start
let's just put basically these equations
into the into the matrix form. So we
have y1, y2. What was our next step? Y
m
and
[Music]
yn. We'll multiply this by b1
b2 until bm.
Good. So let's do this practice how to
how to how to make it how to build let's
say the first row. So y1 what
are what are the multipliers of the of
the parameters? How will the first row
look like?
Uh once again
you not. And then and then Z. No, I I
didn't hear. You can rep You can reply
in Slovak. Of course, I just I just
didn't hear you. Good. What about uh
what was it? There was U1. What about
U2? Uh Y2.
So the coefficients of B1, B2 until
BM, B1,
no U1, U
[Music]
Z.
Okay. And well, we can start to start to
see the see the pattern. U you not would
would kind of be on a on a diagonal.
Let's let's see where the diagonal ends.
So it's
basically how to how to think about it,
how to visualize it. I usually usually
say
like imagine uh we are just getting some
sort of
a we just represent this u values as a
as a sort of a strip like on a piece of
piece of paper 0 0 and here it's one
which is actually
u ah
u0 u z u1 u2
two and and so on. And now we we take
this strip, we flip it and we and we
paste it at the at the at the correct
correct place place in this in this
matrix. So if we just take this this
strip and we cut
it cut it let's say here that mean we
are we are actually representing the
output at the at the point one yeah we
take you not 0
0 flip it what is this
vertically so we get you not 0
0 we get the second
on. So now we have
already already a
smaller
ah smaller strip. So we take u1 u u not
or u 0 0
0. Good. How was
our
ym? Our ym how would that row look like?
Y
Mhm. Yeah, we
are we are in
the in the past with
that right and then um m
-2 and then dots what will be the last
one
zero.
So this is actually where our diagonal
would finish. This is actually the first
time we are getting like if we are
filling this matrix from top to down.
This is the first time that we are
actually getting a square matrix, right?
Because now we have M rows and we always
had M m columns.
It's important because well at some
point we want to do either let's say
some inverse of this of this matrix or
at least pseudo inverse. Good. So this
is kind of the first full full row.
Uh let's
just let's just finish the the last one.
So can we do it from the from the
memory? How? Why? How? How would it look
like?
U N
-1 N - 2 N N - M. Yeah.
Basically what we what we got here we
can we can stop uh with our with our
data points at at this point and
basically we would get a set of linear
equations which are fully determined.
Yeah the square square system. So we get
m parameters that we calculate based on
the on the m equations.
It's okay fine fine to do. Usually we
just have uh we just have more data.
Usually have we have noise in the data.
So that's why we want to we want to take
more data
points. And uh of course as a as a
byproduct what what we got here. If we
now just uh just start this matrix from
from this row we can actually represent
we can forget about the step response.
we can forget about these these zeros.
Well, these sort of rows will will
always always work for a for a general
form of the of the signal.
Yeah, of course, the good assumption
would be at least some uh some uh uh
some steady state in the in the past,
but it's not always not always
necessary.
Uh so what are these
uh these uh these
numbers this uh m and n? So m
is nothing else uh you would already
um you would already call it this way at
your theory of automatic control
classes. That's the order of the
[Music]
model and basically this n is num number
of number of data points that we take
into
account and uh this one should be of
course we want to find m is the order of
our model. We want to identify m
parameters. So the number of data points
should be at least m. It's very good if
if it's more or or much more if if the
noise is
[Music]
high. Good. Does it make
sense? All right.
Uh so let's uh let's now see how we can
how we can extend this how we can maybe
get to the types of models that you are
more more used to because the types of
the models that you are more used to
would in
this discrete time domain world. Well,
they would look
uh first let's let's get back and
see last time last time we we got our
our transfer function of the of the FIR
model. Yeah. And that one is easy easy
looking very very nice. It's basically
just the numerator uh of the uh of the
transfer function that you are that you
are more used to there is one in the in
the in the denominator.
So
something something which is which is
similar. Well, we can we can keep
this i going from one to one to
m in the
numerator b i
u k
min what I'm talking
about this transfer function already
this is not the time world so this
is D to the power of minus
I and we can extend this
uh this
denominator something
like
two. No, no, no, no, no.
[Music]
Here it will be it will be good to have
to have one because that's that's what
you are you are used to used to see and
there is some
Z to the power of minus minus
I right this is a sort of a transfer
functions that you have seen in your
theory of automatic control. Uh two
there might be even some term which
would
be
responsible. So this
uh the number of the sums this limits of
the sums like n m and nk it's uh what
matlab uses. So I'm just uh I'm just
using uh using the similar similar
notation.
Uh I don't know whether you but you
probably probably studied also also this
term in the theory of automatic control.
What would what would it be responsible
for? Doesn't ring the bell.
when you are
uh what happens for example when you are
simulating uh you have maybe an S
function or whatever whatever
model that gives you the signal
basically at at the time t and you want
to you want
to you want to represent And that uh
since you supply the input at time t,
your next input is only uh you only get
it at time t + one. What do you use in
simuling? What sort of a block?
Mhm. Yes.
Yes. And and what is the what is the
what is the sign here or what is the
Exactly. Which is just well this is just
introducing unit unit delay. Yeah. So
that current output is is going to be
the the the output at the at the next
next step in time. Yeah. We have
something something similar here. Yeah.
This is again a again a delay but a
delay of n k num number of steps. So
this is the way how
to how to represent time delay or
input input
delay and we will kind of exclude it
from uh from our our discussion. it's
maybe more important to to to look at
the look at these terms.
Uh so yes, this uh fraction here, this
fractional transfer function, I hope it
resembles the what you what you see in
the in the theory of automatic control.
And what did the what it would be called
in the identification domain? This would
be
called
auto
regressive. Auto
regressive
model with
I need to shift everything a
bit with exogenous
input. I didn't get this M
there regressive
model
with
exogenous exogenous
Gee, one more
E sounds horrible. I
know.
A maybe make this R
capital.
Of course, the the the name is horrible,
but we have a we have a nice acronym. A
A
RX. Uh let's uh let's let's let's maybe
see how how this model would again work
in the in the time uh time domain. So
let's let's do the backward uh backward
uh Z
transformation. It should be easy. It's
much easier than laplas.
Um what we are basically seeking to find
is the is the is the expression similar
to our to our fear model. we should get
something similar because well our uh
numerator is is is the is the is the is
the is the same thing as uh as we had
for the for the fir
model. So what do you say? How do we how
do we do
that? We are slow or
fast. You were pointing at the watch.
Each uh Z to the power of minus1
represents one one delay. Z to the power
of minus2 would represent delay of uh of
two two time
steps. Two power minus three three time
steps.
What do you say? How how to how to
start? Okay, let me
Make one large fraction from it.
Mhm. One large fraction from it.
Well, well, this is basically basically
what we have. Let's just take uh maybe
let's just take only this part to make
it to make it easy. The input delay can
be can be always plugged
in. Oh,
okay. How did I copy this
guy? Does it work? Yes, almost.
one large fraction of it.
[Music]
Yes. Yeah. So, let's just do the uh
let's just get rid of the fractions by
multiplying by the denominator numerator
denominators
denominators. So what we have y ^ of -1
* 1
+ sum of i until n a i z to the power
min - i is equal to
u z
-1 and we have a sum
I + 1 M B I Z
-1. And now what?
I mean we can we can basically keep this
sums because well we have an we have an
alternative just
Yes. Yes. Exactly. Yeah. This one here
is nothing else than uh no shift at all.
So now now we are just basically do
doing what? If we encounter
uh k
minus
sorry so k minus i is nothing else than
the than the z to the power of minus i.
Right?
[Music]
So, so the first
term is what? Z to the power of zero.
So, y k minus
yk. Is it okay? You seem to be like
shocked by by
this. Okay.
Yeah. YK current point in time no shift
Z to the zero zero zero shift. Okay. Uh
and let's uh since we can build then
later our prediction equation. So let's
keep this one on the left hand side of
our equation and let's let's put the put
the rest to the right hand
side. So we have here minus and we can
just live with the
sum this Z transform is is very very
very nice that it's done so easily
and well no brainer we just have the Z
to the power of minus I we just replace
it by the Y K minus
I good and what do we have
Here we have here our use. Same story
with the with the use. So we get sum
from one to m i
ui k minus k minus
i. Yeah, this is our time uh time domain
time domain
model. Uh how would this uh this would
be called
called MN or NM? Now I do not remember
the order of these MN
order A
RX A RX
model.
Um so why is this
uh why this uh ARX if you
recall how was this called there is auto
reggressive so that's a R part and there
is this exogenous
input we despite the fact it might be a
little little confusing I I give you
that despite the fact that here in the
numerator we have what we before called
fir model. Uh we are we are not calling
this uh this last part to be the fir
part but this is this exogenous input.
So uh this uh this model could quite
easily
uh quite easily live without without
this. So in this form this would be just
called uh AR model. So auto reggressive
model. Why is it auto reggressive? Uh if
you if you look here it kind of
resembles what what we what we used for
our filters last time. So the current uh
so the uh value of the output at current
point in time is given by the by the
past times and this is this means that
it's a this model is regressing on its
on itself that's why the auto
reggressive that's why AR came came
up and uh if if this model should also
be influenced by some external factor
then it's not called external input it's
called exogenous input don't ask me why
there will be some historical
uh lesson behind it but this one can
represent all these all the transfer
functions all the models that you are
already already used to uh quite quite
easily uh you might look of course at
the at the poles at the at the zeros
every Everything everything is is there.
Um let's
see how we
can how we can do the same sort of a
sort of exercise that we did for our for
our previous uh previous uh FIR model
whether we
can whether we can achieve it. So we can
again assume the the same the same setup
that we are just dealing with some step
response step response data. We can just
build build our our
predictions ready for
that. So how would
our Y1 uh prediction look like?
Yeah. But we we need to now now now we
now we need to uh break the sum into the
individual components because
uh because uh we want to we want to get
in into this form. We we wouldn't need
to now see the the the structure in the
in the in the
multiplication. It's possible with the
sums but I think it will be it will be
more complicated. We wouldn't make our
our life easier.
So what will be the the first term?
Exactly.
Exactly. Minus
A1 y which one? y not y z. Mhm.
uh minus and
now the same in the same way as in as in
our FIR model. Well, we we assumed
that before before the step we were in
the in the steady state. So our use were
zero, our y's were were zero.
So same exercise again we are now having
let's just write it formally so minus
a2 what will be the y
which oneus
minus one
Yeah. Until Okay. Now it will be no plus
minuses.
Sorry. A n. Now what will complicate our
uh our task is that we have m and n
order. So the A's will run out uh B's
will run out faster than than the than
the
A's.
Um how will the index of uh of I of of Y
look like?
One -
1 minus n, right?
Good.
Good. All
right. Plus, we do not stop. We do not
finish here. But we already know this
one. Yes. This must be the same stuff as
as our as our very very first FIR model.
Yeah. B1 U1 uh U you not. And then we
are traveling
back back to the
past. B1
U + B2 U -1
+ B
M
U - M. No, 1 minus M. Right?
So the same thing 0 0 - 1 - one and at
the end coefficient we have 1 - n at the
m coefficient we have 1 -
m.
Okay, let's try Y
2. How would it look like?
Mhm. Adam is going to like it. I can I
can see it. I can sense it.
Hus a1 y1. Yeah.
Yeah. So yeah, our our coefficients are
still still the same. Yeah. The sum is
is is still still the same.
Uh so we will always have B1, B2, B3,
A1, A2, A3 and so on. And what what
changes is the is the is the
data. Yeah.
Yeah. This needs exercise and you will
you will get to that. So how was that?
Minus A2.
You you will you will go with this one.
Okay.
until a and now Adam
Good.
Adam, your your time has come.
H what? What?
Yes, that was a subtle hint, but you
didn't. Okay. And
what is the K?
K is Yeah. What is I?
Perfect. Ah, there is plus
plus b.
[Music]
2 -
m. Okay.
Um now uh let's let's do it sim
similarly as as we as we have done
before. Uh we got the pattern. Adam got
the pattern. Very good. Uh so uh now
let's do some some sort of a general
term here. Here it it will it will start
to get messy.
Um which one which uh data points we we
ran out first or in other words uh what
is greater m or or
n which one is which one is larger
larger number? what you are what you are
uh used to if uh if you are dealing with
the is larger n or m n n n n n n n n n n
n n n n n n n n n n n n n n n n n n n n
n n n n n n n n n n n n is n is larger.
Why is that?
Because otherwise it would be physically
[Music]
it's got it's it's correct.
Sorry, it's kind of uh correct. It it
holds more more in the more in the time
domain. Uh in the in the in the discrete
domain, you can basically say it's a it
would be a waste of the waste of the
coefficients because uh you can more
effectively hopefully we will we will
see it you can more effectively store
the past information in the states in
the in the outputs. So you typically
typically uh tend
to have the n being greater or or equal
to m which means if we are now going in
the time order so y1
y2 we we will encounter more likely m on
our
way. So let's continue our our our nice
nice
game. What will what will
our what will the data that we will use
for this prediction be
like? Yeah, we can still make it there.
[Music]
I is one and K is M.
So
nus now it becomes tricky.
on about you.
Did you spot the pattern that the use
will always take the Okay. Take the same
indices.
Yeah. Don't Don't make Yakub laugh
anymore. His his teeth cannot stand it.
Yeah. Ah, sorry.
Mus1 +
B2. Mhm.
Conzine.
Good. Two more to go and then we do the
matrix and then we say goodbye. Uh so
how will how will it be
here and
put
perfect mus right?
mus
zero. What about now?
N - one
Mhm.
Nice.
Ah,
no. Let's continue here.
[Music]
N - two. And the last one.
N - M sounds good. Yeah. I mean the
pattern is always n we take take the k
and we take this number and we subtract
it. So n minus
m n -
m are you still holding for
the so let's say that we that we now
take simil similarly to our fir model
our capital n will be much larger than
the number of coefficients that we that
we have what will be the the most
general but I That's also most
easy. Wait,
we have capital N. Mhm. Mhm.
Is it going to be the same?
Almost.
Yeah.
Exactly.
Exactly. Nothing should change here. And
this is already following the the
pattern. N minus
2 plus
capital.
Okay.
So what about now putting this into the
into the matrix
form? Let's hope I need to always always
make it in this way. So what what are
our our predictions telling us? So we
have
y1 y 2 y what was the first one? Y
M sorry Y
N and Y capital
N. Our parameters here are depends it's
up to us how to how to order them. Let's
say it's A1, A2, A,
N, B1,
B2. Okay, that's
already. Let's make
it more condensed.
Not sure.
A1 until AM B1 until
BM. Well, this is the this is the model
that we want to that we want to learn.
We know Y's and
U's. We need to get a a and
b's, right? We need to find out what are
the what are the zeros, what are the
what are the
poles. Yep.
[Music]
So, so what do what do you say? How can
we how how how would this this matrix
look like? Let's start with the easiest
one. So our
A1 let's plug in maybe we can plug in
this these were the these were the zeros
but we need to keep the the
columns in the place
almost minus y not exactly
and then some
zeros and
[Music]
then I'm just trying to estimate the
minus you not
no plus
thanks What comes next?
Those zer are
the elements of many. Yes.
Why is that? Well, how many how many
columns we have? We have n plus m
columns. Yeah, this matrix is is wide.
Mhm. What about here? Y2.
Mhm.
Exactly. So, how would the how would the
M look like without looking back?
Y mus one, right? Mhm.
Until where did where did we finish
these
Y's? So, YM finished at
[Music]
I don't know whether it's zero. This is
this is already already general. It can
be Yeah. But ah okay. You mean ah no no
no no no. Okay. Okay. Okay, I know what
you what you meant, but no.
Yeah,
m -
n this
one. Yeah.
Okay, the next
row, this one is already easy,
right? N - one, n minus, n minus 2
until y -
y and in terms of u we have well we are
just repeating right?
[Music]
You ah no n minus
one. How is it going to be? Already lost
track.
n ah n minus one n minus 2 and this is y
not but m n -
m and the last
one n
-1 - n -
2 y n - n
U N - one U N Ah
no but the last one was capital N minus
M. We have made it. You you'll try to
build these matrices automatically at
your at your exercises. Did we get the
same metrics as we as we should have
based on the exercise?
Let's hope, right? Yeah.
Seems good. You will you will find out.
Yeah, it's it's it's much better. It
would be even much better exercise if we
made some mistake and you will correct
that mistake at the at the
exercises. Okay. Any questions, comments
to that? You can say that you hate
matrices. You're good,
right? Okay, there are no comments.